a ceasefire between Israel and Islamic
Jihad militants has held through the
night in Gaza it follows three days of
violence which left more than 40 people
dead and hundreds in hospital in a
statement U.S President Joe Biden
praised the truce and called on all
parties to fully implement the terms and
to ensure humanitarian supplies flow
into Gaza
to the streets of Gaza to celebrate the
Egyptian brokered truce moments after it
went into effect
[Applause]
we hope that we will not have wars we
are a people and we have the right to
live our lives in Gaza we do not want
Wars every two years or every two days
a flurry of airstrikes and Rocket
attacks traded in the minutes leading up
to the ceasefire which went into effect
at 11 30 PM local time news of the deal
was greeted with relief at this mall in
southern Israel
I hope it will last and that we'll live
a bit more quietly
this fire aims to end the worst fighting
in the region in more than a year
[Music]
authorities in Gaza say more than 40
people including children have been
killed since Israel began its offensive
on Friday hundreds more were injured and
many buildings reduced to Rubble Israel
has called it a preemptive operation
against anticipated Islamic Jihad
attacks
[Applause]
two of the group's most senior leaders
in Gaza were killed in the strikes
Islamic Jihad lobbed a barrage of
rockets towards Southern Israel in
response
the group's leaders spoke to reporters
from Tehran after the truce went into
effect
the enemy wanted to break Islamic Jihad
but we did not break on the contrary the
Islamic Jihad movement is still strong
and stable and even more powerful the
achievement is clear
he said Egypt would also work to secure
the release of Islamic Jihad leaders
being held by Israel
a correspondent Tanya Kramer is standing
by in Jerusalem Tanya is that ceasefire
actually holding
well yes the ceasefire agreed last night
between Israel and the Palestinian
Islamic had appears to be holding this
morning it went into effect at 11 30
local time there had been some Rockets
being fired afterwards but since the
night has been acquired it was mediated
mainly by Egypt uh Qatar and other key
players here in the region
now in the morning here we're hearing
from the Israeli home front command
they're saying there are gradually you
know easing the restrictions on people
living in the south of Israel that were
under heavy rocket fire in the past days
you know that they still need to stay
near shelters but that might be Easter
you know in the morning hours of course
we also heard from a statement last
night from the Israeli Prime Minister
that if there's any violation of the
ceasefire Israel would respond strongly
we heard similar words from Islamic
Jihad said that if the commitments made
in this agreement payment they would
also respond with a rocket fire now the
problem is we don't know exactly all the
details of this agreement mediated by
Egypt which will still continue to
mediate as we understand in the coming
days there was a statement in the um
official news Egyptian news agency
saying that Egypt committed to work on
releasing to our Islamic Jihad
militants that are currently imprisoned
in Israel that was one of the key
demands by Islamic Jihad but I think
also the focus is now of course on Gaza
because people were asking whether you
know Israel will ease further the
closure if there's anything like that
coming up and of course if the crossings
will be opened as before this escalation
you know because there's a need to let
in fuel and goods are from there the
power plant that stopped on Saturday
reducing you know electricity in this
trip and of course there's a lot of
humanitarian Aid needed at the moment
Israel says it's taken out the military
leadership of the Islamic Jihad group in
Gaza how weakened are the militants
[Applause]
well I mean this is at least what Israel
says or the Israeli government we heard
again a prime minister yaela Pete Sunday
night just before the ceasefire went
into effect talking to Mayors in the
south of Israel saying that Israel
achieved its goals and many we heard
also other officials talking about in
the last 48 hours that by killing those
two senior militant commanders from the
Islamic Jihad that they think they have
restored this deterrence that they have
weakened the organization just by
sending the message that they have the
intelligence to get to these people
they're not you know working in the open
and also message of course in to the
Israeli public but of course also you
know we've seen that time and in time
and again and analysts agree here that
of course those people will eventually
be replaced and in the absence of any
political solution you know another
conflict might be just around Corner
Tanya Kramer for us thank you very much
for bringing us that update